early in the history of warfare man
learned that the best formula for
victory
was compounded of striking power
mobility
and self-protection the us is easily the
most powerful country to have ever
existed
and it certainly spends more on its
military budget than any other country
does today
that's all pretty well known but less
well-known is the fact that the u.s
has around 800 military bases around the
globe
this map can't even show that many dots
these are just
200 or so dots to give you an idea of
where these bases are clustered
these bases are everything from massive
military compounds to small airstrips in
the middle of the ocean
if you combined all the foreign bases
that every other nation has
outside of its own borders you get a
total of about 30.
there's never been a country with such a
massive global presence
and the big question is how did these
bases get there in the first place
and how much is it costing u.s taxpayers
to keep them open
[Music]
most of these bases cropped up after
world war ii when the u.s
set up in places like germany and japan
to help maintain peace
after an era of intense global war but
we cannot expect these people to discard
nazi ideas
with the casual air with which they
abandoned their uniforms
slowly steadily they must be taught the
fundamentals of democracy
our task is to supervise this training
in democracy
even though these countries are now
stable robust democracies and allies
the us still has 50 000 troops in japan
and 54 000 in germany the korean war
brought an influx of american
infrastructure
into the korean peninsula where we now
have 28
500 troops stationed the cold war made
the u.s expansion to every corner of the
globe imperative to u.s strategic goals
here in russia you see the reason why we
are spending billions of dollars in
defense production
why your family is paying the highest
taxes in our history
but even now that the cold war is over
there's not a place on earth that's not
still covered by u.s military influence
this includes everything from
naval compounds like those in guantanamo
bay
to small drone bases like those in the
horn of africa
to little-known posts in the middle of
the indian ocean like that of
diego garcia
and it's not cheap keeping us foreign
bases open
costs taxpayers between 70 and 100
billion dollars per year
that's more than any other government
agency receives in taxpayer money
besides of course the department of
defense itself
taxpayers pay between 10 and 40 000 more
per soldier stationed abroad
than they do for those stationed here
domestically but this cost
seems to be worth it to most lawmakers
the idea that u.s military leadership
provides an indispensable stability to
the globe
is now a fixture of our global strategy
and our foreign policy
in an uncertain world full of
breathtaking change
the one constant is american leadership
you can't have stability without
american leadership there's only one
nation in the world capable of rallying
the freedom-loving people of this planet
to confront evil american leadership is
not
just respected it is required so over
the past 70 years the u.s has set up
bases
all over the world in response to
threats and then they just never left
these 800 bases around the world
represent a massive system
of military power that isn't often
talked about
and it's us the american taxpayers that
are financially supporting this
we have all decided that it's worth it
to pump a hundred billion dollars out of
our economy
to keep these bases open on the far
corners of our globe